[Music]
thank you we're excited to be here with
leopards today
my name is marianne i'm a campaign
manager with kaya jib and i'll be acting
as an additional host and the moderator
for the question and answer section for
today's webinar
i'd like to take a moment to introduce
our speakers for today
we're joined by dr biata litzenberger dr
joe foster and ajaya tavlay
and today our speakers are going to take
us through a webinar on fastq to final
report an ultra fast workflow for
comprehensive genomic profiling
and before we get started i just have a
couple quick product disclaimers to show
relating to the proper use of the
products that we'll be discussing today
again thank you everyone for joining us
today and i will now hand the
presentation over to dr biata
lutzenberger thank you
thank you very much for the nice
introduction and thank you all for
joining us today
kaijun is the leading provider of
genomic and clinical knowledge for
scientists and clinicians using
augmented molecular intelligence
phd scientists engineers and ontologists
blend artificial intelligence methods
and human intelligence to curate the
world's largest and trusted source of
molecular knowledge the kind of
knowledge base
while machine learning techniques help
to rapidly prioritize extract and index
and see evidence that inform our subject
matter experts
every piece of evidence is manually
reviewed and further manually processed
to curate complex biological processes
and clinical evidence to achieve deep
insights with high precision
kaiju knowledge space drives powerful
analytics visualization and reporting
tools that enable researchers
clinical scientists
and data scientists
to excel their cutting edge research and
clinical decisions
now over the last years we have seen a
trend to use larger and more complex
panels
a consolidation into whole exomes and
even whole genome sequencing and more
companies hospitals and universities
use a multi-atomic approach to decipher
tumor molecular profiles
therefore having an appropriate
bioinformatics infrastructure
to deal with the immense amount of data
to call variants as well as data
interpretation
to decipher meaningful variants from
variants of uncertain significance
becomes even more challenging
thus pathologists and clinical labs are
challenged to maintain turnaround time
without jeopardizing quality for patient
management
according to an independently conducted
survey
the most significant bottleneck in the
ngs workflow is the length of time spent
analyzing data
with over a quarter of researchers
surveyed report that performing ngs data
analysis requires more than a week
now the goal of kyogen's and dna nexus
partnership is to eliminate this
bottleneck and allow labs to adopt new
panels scale and volume and deliver with
confidence accurate patient reports to
clinicians and we will talk in the next
30 to 45 minutes on how dna nexus and
collagen can successfully help your lab
to scale or launch your clinical genomic
profiling services
dna nexus and kaijun build this
partnership because our platforms bring
ngs data analysis from any ngs test in
one place
both platforms are cloud-based platforms
that
allow for rapid scaling in volume and
turnaround time
but still complying with the regulatory
standards and
without the need to develop advanced
bioinformatics skills
and so therefore those platforms
synergize in reducing the data analytic
bottleneck of ngs tests
the synergy in our platforms result in
an integrated workflow
taking users seamlessly from fast queue
to report
qci's second analysis pipelines are
built on the dna nexus platform
which is connected to qci interpret for
variant interpretation and reporting
at this point i'm going to hand over to
joe to provide a deep dive into the dna
nexus platform
thanks beater and with that i'd like to
briefly describe the dna nexus
end-to-end platform for accelerating
diagnostics
so the dna makes this cloud platform is
fundamentally about supporting cost
reduction and operational efficiency in
diagnostics by addressing your needs
across the entire diagnostic test life
cycle
test development is rapid encouraging
industry best practices in the use of
workflow languages pipeline maturation
from r d to testing to production is
seamless and with robust scalability
handled out of the box cost saving
opportunities across the data lifecycle
become the focus and what we're finding
is that smart operations are finding new
benefits from a granular and secure
approach to data access enabling
previously untenable collaborations
with the platform built on top of public
cloud infrastructure dna nexus is an
end-to-end product for the scaling of
diagnostics and more broadly life
sciences research
whether users are informaticians
clinical scientists or administrators
the dna nexus platform enables a wider
team to bring their significant
experience to bear
on clinical service delivery in a mode
that makes sense for them
and thanks to dna nexus's world-class
security quality and compliance posture
whole teams are unburdened from complex
infrastructure management regulatory
challenges and so they can focus on
what's truly valuable to them
and with rich integration capabilities
by design dna nexus is built to be the
beating heart of any high performance
diagnostic operation
so what does that actually look like in
practice aside from scalability and
security what concrete functionality
does dna nexus provide to help
diagnostic teams meet and exceed their
targets
well it's about securely sharing the
right data in the right manner with the
right people
it's about executing production
workflows on the cloud potentially at
the click of a button
it's about collaborating on ad hoc
statistical analysis and report
production
up to also launching custom web
applications so people can get very
customized hands-on experience with
their data
and finally underlying all of this is
ubiquitous programmatic access i'm about
to jump you into a live demo of the
platform where you'll see some of this
in action now for the sake of
demonstration i'm going to show you
mostly iui to get to a lot of topics
very quickly but behind all of that
it's calling an api and on top of that
api we layer language bindings in python
java and c plus we have a toolkit as
well so that you can programmatically
control the platform which is going to
increase the scope for integrations and
also automations as well
so with that then let me dive into the
actual platform
i'm in my browser here i've gone to
dnanexus.com
and anyone can register an account
up here but as i already have one i'm
going to click login my username my
password in my case my account is two
factor authenticated so i'm going to
quickly type in my second factor here
and log into the platform
once i've logged into the platform i'm
presented with a list of projects that i
have access to
those projects then are the unit of
sharing on dna nexus it's inside of them
that we put
files that we might put applications
that we might put workflows or even
databases and then we share that as a
unit with other users and groups of
users on the platform
so for example i can see here i have a
project with about 152 gigabytes of data
inside of it i'm an administrator and
we'll see what these roles mean in a
moment and i'm the only member of this
project as it stands
the project that is hosted in aws u.s
east so we've got guarantees around the
residency of this data not just from a
storage perspective but any compute
that's done on the
objects in this
project will also be done in that same
region i can also see where it bills to
at the bottom of all of this is public
cloud infrastructure where we pay for
what we use and so i have something
called an organization
where me and my colleagues have a shared
group of funds from which we can draw
down on to perform activity on the
platform in the form of storage compute
and sometimes egress if we remove data
from the platform as well
now let me click on a project here
and show you what it looks like it's a
typical file explorer type view i've got
some folders
inside of these folders
perhaps i've got some files and here you
can see
a set of fastq files which are actually
from a transcriptomics analysis that
we're going to do in a moment
these files then
would originally have been uploaded to
this project through this feature here
at the ad i can upload data i can
centralize data from ftp servers and
perhaps native aws s3 buckets as well
through the ui for uploading data from
my local machine perhaps is a simple
drag and drop interface here where i
drop the files click upload and those
will rapidly be centralized into
this project and the security of the dna
nexus platform
once the files are in there perhaps what
we might want to do next is actually
analyze them so in this case i mentioned
these are rna seq data and so i'm going
to go to our tools
tools library up here
where i'll be presented with a list of
all of the applications
and workflows which are
applications that have been constructed
together in a particular order that i
can run
so the public tools library is already
filled with many many many common
bioinformatics tools ready to work at
scale on the cloud
in this case i'm interested in a
particular workflow that we abbreviate
teq
our transcriptomic expression
quantification workflow
and if i click this
i can run that workflow
really simply
and so what we're about to see is a
schematic of that workflow you'll see uh
all of the different components and how
they're stitched together but the first
thing i need to do is select the project
in which to run it now in this case i'm
going to run that workflow inside the
project we just had a look at our
rna-seq demo project
if i select that project then
it's now
that i'm going to be able to
use the files in that project to run
this workflow on them
and i simply do that by clicking on the
analysis inputs and adding the required
required files now in this case we're
actually going to run a version of this
pipeline that's going to run star and
then rsem this particular workflow is is
a little bit branched in that you can
choose the underlying tools that you
might use in this type of expression
quantification analysis we're going to
use star and rsem and for that i need to
give a particular set of reference data
so i need an alignment reference which
is just a file that sits inside of
my project so i'm going to add that
we need a transcript annotation as well
again it's just a file that sits inside
my project in this reference data folder
that i created
because we're using rsem we're also
going to need this quantification
reference as well so i'm going to click
in my reference data
and it's here that i have that
and now
i'm going to start actually adding my
data i want to analyze now you can see
here i can add my reads
and my paired reads
to this
you might be asking yourself the
question well i've got more than one
sample that i want to analyze right for
that we use a functionality called batch
mode which i simply turn on here i say
that these are my batch inputs these
reference files are going to stay
exactly the same but i want to do the
same analysis over lots and lots of
pairs so i can configure my batch here
by simply adding files and we saw
earlier it was in fast queues
here that i've got
six pairs
of fast key files for analysis i'm going
to select them
and then it's telling me what regular
expression it thinks is going to pair
these properly together so i'll select
those and i just do a quick sanity check
and yet that looks like it's pairing
beautifully
and then i complete my changes at this
point i've got six
batches of this analysis ready to run so
on on six paired samples in order to
execute it then
i just click start analysis
at this point dna nexus is going to the
cloud it's gathering in a just-in-time
fashion the correct um
instance types for all of these
different individual applications that
go in this workflow here
okay so this is what running a tool
looks like if i go back to
uh our actual project then
i actually ran that earlier so let's
take a look at what some output data
really look like so in outputs here
if i show you it's here i've got a
folder
per
sample that was run and if i look at one
of these for example sample six here i
can see all the files that were produced
in that analysis how do i know they were
produced in the analysis well if i click
on any one of them these files carry
with them a chain of provenance that
perfectly describes
where they've come from so i can see
that this bam file was produced by me on
a particular date by running this star
mapping application which has a unique
id
inside of this job
you can see there's a hyperlink and i
can actually click on these jobs
to then see how long it ran for
what was the cost
what were the inputs and outputs
more broadly then to get a view of
execution we can actually click on the
monitor tab
and it's in that monitor tab where we
have a list of all of the jobs that have
ever run in the context of this project
and you can see i've done a few things
i've
fetched some reference data for example
and then i've generated genome indexes
and prepared uh
files for rsem as well
here then all those files that i ran
earlier and i can see the whole workflow
that we saw you know averaged about two
hours and 10 minutes and cost about a
dollar and a half to run what we're
seeing at the top happening in real time
here is jobs completing these are those
six
um
batches that we just launched moments
ago
they've only taken a minute to run
though and they've cost zero dollars is
something going wrong well in this case
no what's actually happening here is the
dna nexus platform is clever enough to
understand that we've run this exact
analysis before at least for these four
and it doesn't need to do it again
so rather than wasting your time and
your money it completes the job
immediately and if we were to look at
that job
and we were to look at its outputs
all of the outputs are available here
and they're actually from those previous
jobs so that's a great time saver it's a
great cost saver it's particularly
useful when you're in that
r d phase of your pipelines and you're
testing them and iterating on them quite
rapidly
okay
a couple of minutes left uh to show you
a few more things once we've got a
project like this that's got lots of
interesting things in it probably comes
down to sharing it so in the top right
is where we can click and i can use a in
this case i'll shout out to my colleague
ray moran
where i can maran where i can give him a
level of access that's appropriate to
what he's intended to do with this
project so as a viewer i can invite ray
and he's going to be able to see what's
in this project and potentially download
the data as an uploader ray's going to
be able to start bringing new objects
into this project and incurring storage
cost as a contributor things get a bit
more interesting and so it's here then
that he'll be able to actually start
running his own analysis in the context
of this project and then finally as an
admin he has the keys to the city he's
the same role as me inviting people
uninviting people and modifying their
permissions
so there's a very simple sharing model
here where we create projects we put
into them or we generate within them
files using applications and workflows
and then we share that as a unit with
people or other groups of people on the
platform as well
finally then the last thing i'll show
you is workflows are fantastic for
production uh
work there's often a need to
do more statistical and ad hoc analysis
as well and for that we provide a
jupiter lab environment
it's very simply launched by clicking
new jupiter lab up here
we give it a name
we associate it to a project again
that's going to set the context for what
access to data it has and
who's paying for the underlying compute
for this um jupiter lab environment
we're backed by the cloud as i mentioned
and so there's the full power here from
kind of desktop spec hardware all the
way up to these kind of two terabyte of
memory 128 core instances as well
i simply
click start environment and from there
i can
open this jupyter lab environment once
it's spun up and as an https web
application we're in a place now where
bioinformaticians
will be able to
for example
access a terminal
start writing their own python bash and
our scripts there's no restriction here
on the tools that they use and in my
case i've got some pre-existing
notebooks in my project that i might
execute in this environment for example
here i have a notebook for performing
differential expression analysis which
at the end of it gets me down to my
volcano plot here
okay
with that then i'd like to pass the mic
to aj who's going to walk us through the
end to end process that marries the
scale and the security of dna nexus with
the deep expertise and trusted analytics
from kaijin thank you
hey everybody
so this is uh ajay and i'm i'm going to
kind of talk to you about
qci secondary analysis
powered by the dna nexus platform so in
the session you already heard about
uh joe talking about the dna nexus uh
platform itself and you heard my
colleague viata talk about the
partnership
and now i'm going to talk about what
what the actual product is right like
what what
do you get out of this partnership as a
customer so i'm going to talk about the
qci secondary analysis
product that is powered by the dnn
access
platform
so
it's extending on what joe said uh
before uh
you now have an idea of what the data
and access platform is
but from a partnership perspective what
we have done is we have uh made
available
uh pre-built
pre-optimized pipelines for your data
analysis on on this uh dna access
platform and these pipelines can be for
any gene panels
exomes uh
that that
are used for high quality variant
detection
and and this this is a sort of a
agnostic product that we are making
available that means any you can you can
enable pipelines for
any panel
by by any vendor
using different tool suites and i'll
focus on that a little more
later
so
what can we enable on this platform as a
part of qci secondary analysis
so we can enable an end-to-end workflow
for you
starting from your raw sequencing data
which is mostly fast view files or ubam
files depending on on the sequencing
technology that you're using so that's
the first part that i want to focus on
that this is sequencing and technology
agnostic so you can support
any of the sequencing technologies out
there including illumina and i am torn
and
once you have your sequencing data ready
uh you you
get this sequence of data into
the dna nexus uh platform
and there are multiple ways to do that
we will provide you with a high speed
high volume uploader uh if you have the
sequencing data on your local
environment like on the sequencing
machine in your local environment
that high volume uploader will rapidly
upload data to the platform
uh or if you're using some some other
cloud-based platform like the illumina
bay space to generate your first two
files you can
directly upload those fast queues you
can pull those that pass your data for
your samples into the dna access
platform and then once you are in the
platform
uh you will have a pre-built
pre-optimized
analysis pipeline
uh on the on the dnxs platform
and then
you can run that pipeline on on the data
that that you imported uh and you can
get the results
and then those results can even
be as if secured uh there are secure
results that can be shared with other
users uh or you can send those variant
uh
calls high quality variant calls
directly to qci interpret software for
weird interpretation that might like the
other touched on uh
briefly in in the session previously
so as you can see that it we can enable
an end-to-end pipeline starting from
your fastq
file raw sequencing data
all the way to actionable report because
not only this platform will analyze your
raw sequencing data to produce high
quality variant calls but it can then
send those results to the qci interpret
software where you can interpret those
variants and then
produce that that final clinical
actionable report
uh from from the qci interpret platform
so yeah just to focus on the advantages
of what you're you're getting here with
the qci secondary analysis on the dna
access platform
so
uh
we are sequencing technology agnostic so
we can support any sequencing technology
including illumina ion current
are the most popular ones
and then
this is panel agnostic so we can enable
a pipeline for any panel from any vendor
so it can be a kaijen seat panel it can
be like the illumina tso 500 panel and
it can be an agilent panel so if we can
build a pipeline for for any uh panel
from any vendor out there
and then the third thing to focus on
this is also tool agnostic so it's it's
not like you are locked into just using
the clc tool suite uh most of the
pipelines we do enable using our
clc genomics uh tool suite that is that
is uh well known in the market
but uh we are not uh
sort of limited to that we we can even
enable pipelines by other vendors as
long as we have access for example we we
have even enabled the illumination 500
analysis pipeline which illumina
published uh on on this uh platform
so
as in for for many of the pipelines we
do use our clc genomics tool suite uh
because that is that is also a very
well-known and and uh high quality
analysis tools
uh but we are not uh
limited to that we can also enable other
tools on on the platform as as easily
so so this platform is also tool
agnostic and
and this platform does connect to
our qci interpret platform where you can
then rapidly produce your your
actionable results
so so this is what we have enabled uh on
on the dna platform and this is what uh
qci secondary analysis is
is a pre-built pre-optimized pipelines
that will take you from your raw
sequencing data
all the way to actionable results uh
quickly
now moving on so i just wanted to sort
of focus on certain bullet points of
what you get from qci secondary analysis
and and what you get from this uh
partnership that we have done with dnnxs
so the biggest advantage uh the first
one is that panel agnostic workflows
so we can enable workflows uh
for any panel by by any vendor and any
size of the panel that's it ranging from
kiss 500 to a whole x zone and then even
smaller panels like 30 40 50 g panels
and from any vendor
so
that's that's the biggest advantage
because then you you uh
it's not like you only support ic or we
only support a particular vendor uh you
have a choice of choosing your panel
vendor and we can build high quality
analysis pipelines for that
i wanted to focus on the bulletproof
security uh because especially for
clinical labs uh running uh patient data
to this platform this is very important
for them and
joe focused on this uh in his
presentation of the of the platform uh
but because we have partnered with dnnxs
uh the dance the dnxs platform has
bulletproof security and and all the
required certifications and security and
compliance certifications
uh that that we
uh inherently
get to take advantage of because we are
building the pipelines on that platform
and that platform itself is is highly
secure and and has all the compliance uh
certification so you
uh
can run your your patient samples on
this cloud platform and not worry about
uh
security the third important bullet
point is workflow optimization
so
not only do we enable uh
pre-built pipeline
but we optimize this pipeline for for
your
own
lab or your organization so
even though it's the same panel we have
observed that depending on on the lab
processes and and how your lab processes
processes the wet lab of of the panels
or the samples the the results can be a
little different
and and then
we sort of account for those uh
differences in in the workflow
optimization process that we do
where we set the parameters of the
workflow
that suit your
data the best and and this course leads
to high quality variant calls that's
that's the advantage and
from your side
you can just upload the data press a
button and and you get the results so
you you don't really
need to then tinker with the parameters
of the workflow and be assured that you
you will get the high quality results so
and then for a clinical pipeline
it's mostly best to keep it locked down
anyways and and which is what we do in
the optimization process we publish a
highly optimized pipeline that you don't
really have to worry about
the quality of the results that we get
and then there's no significant local
hardware requirement so i said this is a
cloud-based
platform
you don't need to maintain
local bulky local servers especially as
if you're running
panels of larger size
you you don't need to maintain any sort
of uh local hardware or if you are
scaling if you're going from a smaller
panel to a larger panel or if you're or
if your sample volume is just increasing
uh you you don't need to like buy more
servers or buy more local hardware
because this is a cloud platform it is
highly scalable
so
if your volume increased in the future
or if you add an extra panel or an extra
asset uh it's it's
you do not have to do anything on your
side the cloud platform is is very
scalable
uh and and
can accommodate this increase in in the
sample volume or or if you add add a new
panel
and then finally uh worldwide world
class expertise so
uh
we have been doing this for for multiple
years we have a global team who is an is
an expert at building
these ngs uh workflows and then you have
the dna access platform which has been
around for more than 10 years uh which
is a solid cloud-based platform for for
running these pipelines so
with the pipeline itself you are
guaranteed of getting high quality
results uh variant results for your
assay and then because you're running
this on the dna nexus platform uh you
get all the advantages of the platform i
said like scalability reliability and
and then bulletproof security
so you you partner with us and and then
you you get uh
all this expertise in in building your
ngs workflows and then you can focus on
doing what you do best uh that is
running the assay and then getting the
results
to the patients in a timely manner
just focusing on how simple it is to
analyze an entire sequencing run with
this platform
so
step one is to i said get the sequencing
data into the platform which and and i i
touched on the multiple ways to do this
so you can either use that uploader tool
or or if you are using some other
platform there's like face space there's
there are there are ways of getting data
directly from that platform
into here
uh
so step one is to retrieve the data into
or get the return to this platform which
is which is very easy with the different
ways there's flexibility there
then you just select the samples
and and you can select the entire run
also
and and then you just click on start
analysis and and that's it uh
once you do this you can
go have a cup of coffee
the system will even send you a
notification
once the analysis is complete
and and then
you you are ready for for further
processing of the data
because the dns
the dna nexus uh platform is flexible
uh
i just wanted to focus on uh the bulk
uploader and and the desktop based uh
client that we have built for this uh
platform so
uh
what this focus is what the focus here
uh what i wanted to focus on more is
flexibility right so
there are multiple ways of interacting
with this platform
so
especially for data upload if you're if
your data is on the local environment
you can just use this very lightweight
uh
desktop software that we have to just
drag and drop data
and then
even run the analysis and then download
the data right from this very
lightweight uh client that we have
and of course the the
the work is happening on the a nexus
environment
but you you will never need to go out of
this uh
portal if you if you don't want to
uh and then of course there is the dnn
nexus portal itself that you're focused
on that that has
uh
also all really good functionalities
which you can take advantage of
so but just for your day-to-day running
analysis uploading and downloading data
you you don't need to go to that portal
you can you can even do the do that
easily just from this uh
desktop client uh that that we have
built for for this uh platform so this
platform is is very flexible so there
are also a lot of apis available not
only for the dnxs platform but also for
the qci interpret platform
so if you do have like software
development support on your side
you can you can even build
a whole automated end-to-end without any
sort of manual intervention
all the way to the final actionable
clinical report
you are you could even engage our
professional services team to to build
such uh end-to-end uh right from past
view all the way to actionable report
workflows uh for you
so there are a lot of options uh that
you you can take advantage of a lot of
flexibility with the platform and and i
already went over the the advantages
that you have and then
uh finally uh
the platform also allows you to view
uh
files that are large in size like the
bam files like the read file ups for for
your samples right in the
cloud
platform itself
which makes it very easy you don't need
to download all the big bang files onto
your local machine and then use some
other tool to do it on your local
machine you can directly view the read
pile up uh in in in the dna access
platform itself in the cloud platform or
if you have access to to some local
software like the clc uh workbenches
that we have
then then you can view that through the
clc workbenches also so it's it's
again very very flexible based on what
you want to do
we we can enable that so
so
yeah just to sort of uh recap what i i
talked about about this platform so qci
secondary analysis uh powered by dnxs
uh yeah the key points is uh panel
agnostic workflows highly optimized
workflows uh and and end-to-end
workflows from from all from fast q all
the way potentially uh actionable
clinical reports in in a very short time
can can be enabled uh
through this platform
and thank you so much for listening to
me today and and thanks to my colleague
biata and and joe
thanks rj for the overview on qci
secondary in the last few minutes i
would like to walk you through the
remainder steps of the tertiary analysis
workflow
in this step pci takes the input from a
qci secondary which can be a vcf file or
a combination of
other files such as a csv or tsb file
and
contextualize this file
with a disease
to be able to match the appropriate
content
for each variant
so at a high level
basically the data files are uploaded
including the patient's disease type to
allow for the accurate display of
disease-specific content
in the first step here the variant
filtering step the variants are
prioritized based on the most clinically
relevant variants
every variant will be automatically
classified according to the amp and acmg
guidelines
and associated with appropriate
treatments and trials
in the second step you will retrieve
ready-to-use parent and disease-specific
summaries without the time-consuming
step of writing those by yourself in
addition our experts provide you with a
second opinion on the varying
classification to increase the
confidence and the accuracy of your
classification
the qc platform provides a flexibility
for customization of the workflow
and also the pdf report at the end
so how does qci display
a patient's molecular test
so what you see here is the variant list
of
an ngs test
of an acute myeloid leukemia sample
each row represents an alteration
detected in the tumor tissue
and the different colors such as red and
pink display the keysight computed
pathogenicity of an alteration
the bottom center
indicates the qci computed actionability
classification
and the smaller batches
to the right are informational batches
and provide an initial
clue what information is available for
this variant
such as a variant is sensitive to
therapies or has prognostic implications
so this view basically provides a broad
overview of the patient's molecular
profile
now you can transparently review the
prioritization cascade and review
filtering parameters that your lab has
set
you can also walk up and down the
filtering cascade to review variants
that are filtered out at each step if
needed
and the transparency is useful um to
also identify low allergic function
acquired resistance mutation or
diagnostic mutations
they may not necessarily pass to the
bottom of the cascade however this
transparency still provides you the
flexibility to then report
those variants from different
cascades in your in your filter for each
alteration that is detected in the
patient's profile
qci provides a one-stop shop organized
in several expandable sections for you
to review detailed information
about the alteration in the context of
the user-submitted phenotype
in the interest of time i'm not able to
dive into the details of each section
but wanted to point out
two sections
the first section is the functional
impact section
which provides you with a written
summary
of the molecular function
you can also access the curated evidence
via hyperlinks to the bibliography
and on top of that you'll be able to
review
a predicted biochemical impact from
various prediction tools
and the combined knowledge allows you to
confidently understand the functional
impact and relevance of this mutation
the second section that is front and
center is the varying details page of
pci
and that is the assessment section which
displays the computed actionability and
pathogenicity criteria
here i want to focus on the
actionability of this variant
all tiers that are applicable will be
shown to transparently indicate the
actuality options for this alteration
for each tier the underlying clinical
evidence can be viewed which provides
transparency in the sources that support
each tier
and if you would navigate to the
treatment section
applicable treatments and clinical
trials are pre-selected for the draft
report
one thing to note is that the user has
still full control of adjusting the
actuality criteria
by
removing or adding
the criteria
or adjusting simply the pathogenicity of
actionability at the bottom of the
screen that i'm showing here
the last step
is the report building step
and it allows you to generate
comprehensive reports in minutes without
the time-consuming step to write
interpretive comments by yourself
in this review and report page qci
displays all variants that should be
reported
for variants that are clinically or and
biologically relevant you will see a
highly structured interpretive comment
with every sentence backed up by
references
the user has editorial control
to refine the content for the report add
or remove a piece of information change
the wording or otherwise revise the
content and these changes can be saved
and will be easily accessible for future
cases
and within minutes you can generate an
oncologist ready report which provides a
comprehensive overview of the patient's
molecular profile
the expert
variant and disease-specific summaries
are provided for biological and clinical
relevant clinical relevant variants as i
mentioned before
here on the first page of the report
you see an overview of potentially
relevant approved treatments
potential resistance
but also a note to oncologists of any
interactions meaning if co-current
variants
may impact the prognostic diagnostic
relevance or may affect therapeutic
outcomes
oncologists will also receive a note if
guideline information from nccn
small eln or who is available
and with that i would like to summaries
of what you've heard today
data nexus and hydrogen partnered to
enable an ultra fast data analysis and
interpretation workflow for genomic
profiling
your lab can accelerate test turnaround
times by using a unified workflow
agnostic platform
dnxs eliminates the need to maintain an
it infrastructure
in-house while remaining compliant to
regulatory guidelines
the end-to-end workflow can flexibly
integrate with existing systems and
workflows using apis
the end-to-end workflow enables
processing of small variants copy
numbers fusions tmb msi and utilize
kaioshin's knowledge space for varying
interpretation which powers dynamically
computed disease-specific bearing
classifications
users get immediate access to
oncologists reviewed interpretive
comments for their reports
and
weekly updated scientific literature
from pubmed professional treatment
guidelines drug labels and local
clinical trials
users retain editorial control even if
the end-to-end workflow is fully
automated
and with that i thank you for your
attention
if you would like to request a demo
please google qci for oncology or qc
interpret one to access the website for
requesting a demo
we would now be happy to take any
questions
thank you for the great presentation
we'll now have time to take some
questions you can submit your questions
in the q a field on your screen
we've already gotten several in so we're
going to go ahead and get started
the first question that we have is can
workflows be edited
i'll take that from the dna nexus
perspective so the platform supports the
editing of workflows in a number of
different ways
firstly they can be controlled by the
input parameter when running them uh in
the ui uh we can also take an existing
workflow and edit it by deleting stages
or dragging and dropping new stages into
it and connecting it together they might
be tools like qc tools for example so
dragging fastqc or multi-qc into an
existing workflow where that makes sense
and then finally for developers
workflows could be deployed to the
platform using normal workflow standards
like whittle or cwl there's also a dna
nexus native approach and pretty soon
we're going to start supporting next
flow as well you know aj did you want to
talk about it a bit from from your
perspective as well
uh yep thanks joe so from a qci
secondary perspective uh the the idea is
the workflows that we can enable
uh from a tools perspective they are
they are locked down so if you want to
switch tools or add more tools
uh that's not something that we we
currently support so you if you do want
to do that then you would have to come
back to us and and we could
uh sort of re-customize the workflow to
do it but when we enable the workflow
it's it's locked down from a tools
perspective
we do
have certain parameters qc parameters
that we could leave open depending on
your requirement for a qci secondary
workflow
great thank you joe and ajay
the next question we've gotten in is
how to get vcf from v excuse me how to
get vcf from dna nexus to qci
so i can take that one so
we already have an app available on the
dna nexus platform that transfers uh
vcfs uh from from dnxs to to qci and
that app you could have it uh sort of
bundled with your workflow uh so that
automatically vcfs get transferred once
your your workflow uh detects the
variance or you we could even set it up
as it could be sort of a separate step
to upload the vcfs uh to qci so it can
be flexible depending on their
requirement
okay thank you aj
the next question we've gotten in is
can this cloud-based software apply to
custom panels
can take that one again so so yes
absolutely so
one big advantage of this solution is
that we can enable workflows for any any
panel from any vendor
uh regardless of size also so it could
be a whole exome it could be if it is a
500 sized
panel or even smaller panels
okay
thank you
okay i think we have time for a few more
questions
the next one we have is
do you retain a history of the variant
classification
and are you able to search for variants
that we have reported on
so i will take a question as it's
probably geared towards the tertiary
analysis in qci
um
so we retain a history of all varying
classifications um that you have
assessed and that you have also reported
on
the variant classification um is stored
and you can see this in the very details
page within qci so if you see the
variant again you open up the varying
details page
you will see how the variant has been
previously classified when it was
classified who classified it in which
disease it was classified and any notes
that you left around that bearing
classification
the other
tool that you could use is the bearing
directory so you could search by the
gene and then all the variants that you
have previously
uploaded to qci will be available in the
variant directory and then you can
search for the gene and the variant and
how often you have seen those the the
the variant being um
reported in your tool and also then from
there you can go to all the cases um
that uh
where the variant has been seen before
okay thank you viata um i believe this
next question is for you as well
the next question is
is it possible to configure the final
report
yes so the report layout can be
configured based on the data that's in
the xml um so the xml is basically the
underlying basis of how we display the
information in the report we can do
report customization within a tool that
our customers can use by themselves or
we have
custom services that basically can
customize any report any fund any layout
that you wish
to
meet your brand recognition for your lab
okay thank you biata i think we have
time for one more question um i know
we've gotten several more in if we
haven't had a chance to answer your
question today we will follow up with
you by email after the webinar
so the last question is
can you integrate the results seen in
qci i1 into a local lims system
yeah i i can take that one so so yes
absolutely so there are
restful apis available uh for qci and
and not just for qci but also for uh
dnax's
uh platform so you could if you wanted
to even build an end to end workflow all
the way from your fast queue uh to qci
and and back into your limb system and
then it can all be automated so there is
a lot of flexibility available with the
api capabilities
okay
great thank you we are now reaching the
top of the hour again if we didn't have
a chance to get to your questions today
we'll follow up with you by email
once again i'd like to thank our
speakers dr biata
dr joe foster and ajay antavlay and we
also want to thank labyrinths for having
us today and i'll now pass things back
to lab roots um for some final wrap-up
so thank you everyone
you